it's politically incorrect to smoke a
cigar it's politically correct to smoke
weed with this shows how sick our
society is that there's been a war on
cigars but not on marijuana all right
very glad to have our next guest as you
may know some people right away will be
incredibly offended triggered this is
one time two also can get a long shot
here yeah where we covered up our
sponsor Walther they're not gonna be
happy but they don't care they're good
sports with our next guest book of
course Exodus Exodus but the rationale
Bible we've talked with him about that's
before he's also a big cigar guy and
pipe guys so today the entire episode
he's going to teach us the ins and outs
and also mattock and the loaded could go
weird places a little bit of the
legislative fight with with cigars very
different yet the weed folks but still
very real you can follow them on twitter
at dennis prager mr. Prager how are you
sir great to be with you my friend
and I wish I could smoke with you right
now
funny because later today I'm doing my
fire my weekly fireside chat know where
a lot of thank God a lot of people watch
and I smoke a cigar the entire time cuz
I'm in my house right right now I'm at
my radio studio I just finished my my
national radio show so I can't smoke
here but I do within the house I have a
great wife who's totally at peace with
it now by so I I am gonna give you more
philosophy of cigars than you believe
exists okay well let's get it we'll get
into that but first we have to we have
to like this this puppy what are you
well because son computers in here
didn't know if anyone this is just the
standard brick house cigar which
actually for the money isn't is not a
bad cigar in my opinion my favorites are
I think I totally the the Melania I like
a lot I like the the Espanola Residence
Life you know and here haven't you heard
she's been cooped up some button
somewhere he's a but this is just
something that's a little less offensive
for people in the room because you know
sensitive Constitution so it's a normal
brick house the Churchill length yeah
gotcha so I want you to know I tweeted
this out last month by sheer chance I
came across an article
morning news they interviewed the oldest
American I think the guy's 111 or
hundred thousand black guy the black guy
is in the Armed Forces they asked him
they said look we know you're always
asked this but we'll ask you anyway
what's the secret to your longevity and
the guy without blinking just simply
said God and cigars I said this is my
man if he's right I'm going to 116 there
you go what I love about him - he
doesn't get it exactly in first up it
looks like he's smoking very bottom
shelf cigars if you wash it and he goes
thinking is about well that smoke
monster
I don't inhale I do it the healthy way
we're like well I don't know if you'd
say the healthy way but it's certainly
less harmful than inhaling yeah shows me
and he's lighting it's not it's not like
a vegetable it's lighting it on his
stove if you want yes if you watch these
like we had before we have to the first
sketch once we had no lighter with us we
had a lighted on an electric stove which
hit spoiler impossible yes so he does do
that if you watch the video go watch it
I'll send it to you after it is video I
read the article I got to watch the
video you're right he's face version of
stuff my father who passed away at 96
would have gave me given the same answer
yeah got it cigars well I don't want him
I don't want to mislead our audience I'm
not I can't make the medical claim that
cigars lead longevity but speaking of
legging letting in our stuff okay so
first off what's the proper way to toast
and light a cigar for Pilar light first
before that we have the biggest of all
philosophical questions regarding a star
what type of hole do you make on the top
yes okay so those people who don't know
it comes wrapped right and you have to
make a hole obviously you can't breathe
in any smoke right so there are three
types a hole cut which I call
circumcision it's just a hole cut right
right the whole time guillotine
yeah guillotine right another one is a
bullet hole where you get a sharp thing
and you die got here a punch right punch
it in and the third is a v cut it's
shaped like a pyramid sort of it's or
viii and you slide the thing across the
bottom it's steel and it makes a
beautiful indentation and it that's my
favorite
at least rick is the whole car yeah you
know what I have a V cutter and I like
it on bigger gauge cigars not for those
who don't know I was mainly a pipe guy
this is something that Nike Gerry myself
I've to pipe is great it is but I you
were the one who got me into cigars more
by he introduced me to some different
kinds I had smoked before cigars before
now I'm not a certainly changed cigar
smoker but I enjoy them very much I have
a V cutter I like that on bigger ring
gauges for people who don't know they're
different you know they gauge it gauge
by ring size in the United States so
50/50 to I think this is a 50 by 7 a
Churchill sized longer it would take a v
cut I typically do it on 54 or large
right to the v-cut and this is a 9
millimeter punch so a little bit bigger
than the standard punch and this I do
it's just totally opinionated a zoom in
on it can we can we get a zoom on this
the reason now I will tell you this mr.
fragran maybe you can correct me the
reason I like this is if a a punch is
sharp and long it won't realize you know
you can get cheap punches but it does
have to be sharp there's no risk of it
crushing anything or compacting
like so if you don't get a good draw
with a punch you're not going to you
won't get a good draw with any cut is
what I've encountered and it's
convenient because I can keep it on my
keychain if I go through TSA so that's
why a man is this there you go oh there
you go look he's got his whole keep
there you go okay well there is that
there you see yes I usually think it's a
bullet yes
yeah I've seen that too then I showed
them you see I twisted it there and you
could see yeah
and they go oh it's just it's just a
circular razor blade you're free to go
exactly the guys don't know they don't
know okay so toasting this because I
want to get this started as we continue
it's alright this is a very tough
question I have bought the idea that you
light it first and then you start
smoking as a soup supposed to puffing in
wild lighting I have no idea whether
that is an old wives tale or old
husband's tale as it as it is or or true
I have no idea okay I do it
now separately I somehow think it's a
waste of time but I do it anyway I
appreciate your candor so would you do
it in a 45 degree angle and toast the
edges show me here I've got the light
going how are you do you put the net
generally you put the lighter at the
angle on this cigar straight out so what
yes okay that's right
and then just realize okay man I do you
want to make it you been do you purge
when you when you open the lighters
being a little bit difficult here trying
to diss on camera do you purge at all
some people I know they do a quick purge
of it because they claim of the butane
might oh my gosh I am I am NOT in that
arena no okay all right now wait now do
it while puffy gaming you'll see how
much faster of course yeah that's
usually a so I'm not sure it's not
nonsense there you go you see look at
that yeah it may be nonsense
it could be nonsense but I really like
it is if I'm at a cigar bar and they've
got you know women walking around
lighting your cigar for you then I'm
happy if they take their time no that's
called hooters
but I will smoke I'm sure that's a
regular restaurant no no I you know you
you ever been to cigar bars where
they're there oh I have I haven't
experienced the first time I ever had a
cigar I look back and I know the person
was measurement and I get to it has a
cigarillo there so that's a soft flame
lighter there um I went there it was the
Chop House in Grand Rapids member that
jerk yeah a great a great little cigar
great little cigar lodge they would give
you half off on your birthday with steak
the best day cuz it I would go and get
the venison medallions was my birthday
I'd never had us to cut off your entire
meal your entire me or to I never had a
cigar before at this point I said I
don't know what should I do they come up
and they offer all the cuts and looking
back I want to say because it was my
birthday they gave me something fancy I
don't something with a lot of Leggero in
it which is free you'll explain to
people very high nicotine looking back
it was it wasn't
Leflore dominicana might have been in
something like an Opus it was absurdly
expensive I didn't enjoyed it all and
then they kicked us out because I said
they have a party coming in so I'm
driving home I don't nothing like and I
have it basically hanging out of my
mouth with the wind going by because my
wife doesn't want this
our smoke in the car like a snorkel
breathing through it non-stop and I got
home by the way I don't I don't smoke in
the car even for me it's too suggested
or under an arena well I like it I like
to rule like you're sitting in now
that's perfect this is what we do we
have some air exchangers in here so the
studio is good long story short I did
not handle that cigar very well the room
was spinning and I got very sick and
then I learned later on about the
different kinds of cigars so yeah I've
been to a cigar lounge once now let me
ask you this we can get into cigar
philosophy and I want to continue with
that one thing I've noticed for sure
though if you're at lounges for example
I was in Florida there's a cigar lounge
or even in northern Michigan it seems
pretty consistent across the board in my
experience anecdotally that you find a
lot of conservatives in the cigar nose
right why do you think that it's because
it's politically incorrect to smoke a
cigar it's politically correct to smoke
weed which just shows how sick our
society is that there's been a war on
cigars but not on marijuana yes this is
not tampered with our brain well with my
pilot smoke the cigar the entire flight
I would be thrilled feed the entire
flight I would not be thrilled smoothest
landing your ass well it's true I think
about every great every great piece of
fiction of the last several centuries
almost all of them nicotine or caffeine
assembly no I'm not saying people should
go out and light up cigars though they
are no no cigarettes will kill you
hourly kill one third of cigarette
smokers according to the Lung
Association die eventually of lung
cancer and I believe that but two-thirds
don't that's also significant too but I
would not smoke cigarettes remember and
this people don't understand that it
drives me crazy when they say war on
tobacco tobacco's not the issue
inhaling is the issue you are not
inhaling now you are bringing the smoke
into your mouth for a taste right not it
to your lungs for a nicotine effect this
is true something else do I actually
have this up in front of me the FDA
finally released and I'm sure you know
about this but I have to talk about us
for audience the FDA released a study
where
finally eliminated people who smoked two
cigars per day or less handmade cigars
because all the previous studies
included people who are smoking swisher
Sweets and basically cigarettes that
look like cigars at at gas stations and
they found that people who smoked two
cigars per day or less the increased
mortality risk of cancer overall is
statistically insignificant
statistically nonsignificant that's very
rare for the FDA to say something like
that I did not know about that when did
that come out I want to brought this oh
darn it well you know what here people
have already a chance to mention my book
there you go Dennis pretty well think
I'm actually a CS Lewis all of these
guys always over piped her cigars back
and they would philosophize they would
get into theory they get into - what's
the word I'm looking for here the real
depth of the sea of life feel at
theology ology I'm not a good ambassador
right now look nicotine makes you dumb
you should smoke weed it's a smart drug
Exodus God slavery and freedom the
rational Bible highly recommended I've
been very much enjoying it here's a
question for you how often are you
supposed to what's the recommended
amount of before you you you you tant
you know tap the apps' great taps the
ash Dennis before it falls on you I feel
like the therapist in that Annie Hall
the important thing LV is to enjoy
ourselves while we're here what's the
point
he wouldn't do his homework no this FDA
study hold on let me bring it up I
believe it was 2016 and it was actually
they finally eliminated they said okay
and a big reason for this is because
there's been a lot of new FDA
regulations people don't know this work
you owe me a favor
seriously sent it to me okay I will and
we have it here as an overlay for people
watching and again I'm not advocating
that people go out there and just start
chain smoking cigars I'm just saying it
is incredibly rare for the FDA to do and
the reason they did it is because of the
obama legislation they wanted to get
tibet cigarettes out of the hands of
children which we agree with but they
included all cigars it turns out kids
aren't smoking $9 cigars and people pan
you know cigar makers that you have long
long storied history with family cigar
rollers and pipe makers that we
shouldn't be treated the same as
marlboro so
the FDA did have to come out and release
that study of two cigars per day early
date on that study I but well what they
do is they examine their studies and
then eliminated those variables let me
bring it up right here I believe it is
2016
the author's reviewed 22 perspective
epidemiology studies and cigars so if
the FDA acknowledges there's no cancer
risk greater risk then I would argue
that for many people it does bring
longevity because of the calming effect
that it has not the marijuana calming
right just the relaxation with its with
a yummy if that's why we do it I do it
for it's because it's yummy
it tastes great I love the taste that's
why I like a pipe I'm sure looking at
your pipes there yeah yeah because I
love the taste of tobacco tobacco is a
yummy thing I can't I don't i've never
inhaled in my life I'm not Bill Clinton
I would happily admit if I did but I
have it I can't I would I coughed my
brains out if I ever inhaled anything
smoky to my lungs
now what God you started into cigars my
father was a cigar smoker he smoked all
day I lived in 96 as I noted to you
mm-hmm
and when I was about 16 he said I said
dad I'd like to taste one he said fine I
know it's a non-issue he said I think if
I'd have said it at 12 he would have
said fine yeah
so I did and I loved it and that was the
that was it so I've been 16 my daddy was
a smoker and his daddy before him his
granddaddy before but he'll be a pipe
smoker dude you will be a pro smoker -
it is well it's migrant for I felt so
guilty because my mom smoked cigarettes
and quit the day she found she was
pregnant and ever again I'm in French
Canadians they every all of them smoked
cigarettes was a huge culture of smoking
cigarettes my grandfather than hand
smoked a pipe and then he moved on to
those cigarillos later on in life when I
was and you know maybe about nine or ten
and I remember I thought it looked so
cool cuz my my grandfather right he's a
coolest guy and it was in the ashtray
but my parents always told me never
smoke never never smoke if you're
offered and I just took it to look like
my grandfather and it was still lit and
I didn't realize and so a little smoke
one in my mouth I felt bad for years I
felt like I had lied to my parents and I
was I might as well been a smoker but on
to me for
haunted me for years but he didn't live
long because he had up he had a blood
clot and he refused to go to the doctors
but he was up until the day he died
close to 80 was super spry and healthy
so how often would you say you you smoke
a cigar dennis prager whoa I spoke with
everyday and I but it's one a day I very
rarely smoke more than one a day i smoke
one a day then I don't also smoked a
pipe full a day so but when I'm writing
which is all the time and when I'm not
broadcasting or flying or speaking yeah
that's that's it's it's my companion and
I and I love it and a lot of people by
the way like cigar the smell of cigar
smoke yeah I do
a lot my wife does she can't stand
cigarettes can't stand them but she
really does like this by the way your
point about the cigar lounge in every
city virtually every city there's a
place to go and smoke cigars right
excuse me and I go all over the country
constantly and the first thing I do is I
go from the airport I rent a car and I
go to a cigar lounge and you know most
of the time somebody they will know who
I am which I'm not looking I'm not
wanting it happens but the beauty is
even when they don't have a clue who I
am they're so friendly yeah is that the
it's such a bonding male experience
cigar smoking yeah
that's what the guys just talk to each
other it's very and it's it's it's a
great experience the whole thing is and
if there's a young guy there I buy his
cigar well that's right well just make
sure to just follow you around the
country that I'll have the padrone 25th
anniversary mr. Prager would you say is
a mark of a good cigar place what do you
look for when you go to a different town
find a new spot oh well I like that it's
that it's not tiny that you know you can
sit down in a very plush chair have it
have your smoke you could be private if
you want you could talk to people if you
want and you could plug in your computer
I do a lot of writing and cigar lounges
so I I just did an event for my Tampa
radio station and in the hand of a
gigantic I mean truly gigantic allows
the you know campus
a big cigar city yeah and they I there
were 200 people there in a cigar lounge
for me to talk to them and of course
they gave out cigars and so on I do a
lot of cigar events around the country
that's I've looked at some of your old
archives like back as far as 2008 and
there's you broadcasting with your
laptop from a cigar lounge and I thought
that that looks like a lot of fun and
it's becoming increasingly rare places
where you can go and do this but it does
seem like the quality establishments
stick around what what in your opinion
is the mark of a good cigar for people
who may not know want to get into it the
the theories really there are only two
answers to that if you like it it's a
good cigar if you don't like it it's not
a good cigar and and that's true for you
know I mean I'm into audio equipment you
know people say what's the best speaker
so the best speaker is the one you like
and I mind that other sincerely the
other thing is though will it not fall
apart as you smoke it that will occur on
Apple port that's cheaply made cigar
yeah like when I did George Washington
remember and you what did you buy me oh
gosh it was awful it was something
really cheap and NASA we're doing so we
were doing George Washington with a
machine gun it was a sketch and we had
it you know chewed off basically a block
a mile with the tip colors of black it
was like wine dipped or something we
have outtakes of me because it kept
going into my mouth integrating what was
this we had to go to the drugstore last
minute to do this sketch let me ask you
this you've talked about the camaraderie
I will say this why do you why do you
think that is I've had some of the best
conversations when my best writing like
writing in groups with other people do
you think it's because women can just
sit and look each other in the eyes and
talk and men often need a device whether
it's playing pool or sitting down in
smokin acid i think that i think there's
a lot of truth to that and i I'll play
this I've had some of my best talks with
my sons over cigar for that alone it's
been worth it
I just dropped a ash on my desk so I
missed that I'm sorry I meant to warn
you you should have dumped it but I
wanted to see how long it would go on my
part yeah I know as you were time went
from okay but you know the story about
Churchill putting a pin in his cigar
have you heard that day yeah he would
take a pin or like a nail and put it in
ago
so it would keep the ash so long when he
was having diplomacy talks that people
would focus on this crazy long ash and
not what his opponent was saying oh my
god that's why I don't believe it but
it's hilarious it's probably not true
but it is a story Google is well known
and he used to pierce his cigars you
know he would do it no I don't think a
pin is gonna keep the ash anyway that's
it hilarious a riot I have no idea if
it's true one thing I do however is um I
put activated charcoal in this little
mason that's my ashtray and if you put
it the ashes don't smell in there the
one thing that people do cigar smell
nice
ashes never smell nice you want to get
rid of those it's quick oh that's
interesting I didn't even know about
that tell me about it so you know a lot
of the air purifiers that you have
either have an activated charcoal layer
I have bags of activated charcoal you
can do it you know sometimes people tell
you use it for teeth whitening and stuff
I just get it in a powder it's very very
messy so it's important you buy it in a
jar as opposed to a ziploc bag and I put
a few spoonfuls and I tap my ash in
there and you can actually inhale the
ash it's melt and it doesn't smell bad
at all it really does capture the yet
not if I drop it all over myself like a
[ __ ] you put it
can you put it in an ashtray you could
easily put yeah you could put it
anywhere the only thing is it's a very
fine powder so the depth of this helps
to keep it from blowing away at all if
I'm like okay but you put it in that
tray for sure um so we were talking
about that so you think that really adds
to the to the camaraderie is is a device
to sit as I said I I really I love
saying to one of my kids when they visit
or if I visit them they don't live in
California is you know a eight let's
let's have a cigar together and then
it's great yeah and if they're in
California they're they're horrified and
they they shun you you know in Burbank I
live very near Burbank and you can't
even smoke by Burbank City law in a
cigar lounge how does that well are
there any other are no cigar lounges
then there can't that's right or cigar
stores
you can't smoke in a cigar store Wow
right so it's so disgusting it's can you
smoke in a head shop yeah exactly
this is not a joke driving home from
Austin we're spend computer infiltrated
the LGBTQA a IP panel might my friend
John and I wanted to cigar I had one
didn't have one so we stopped today that
unfortunately hatch they call it a smoke
shop right so he stopped and we see all
these bongs never gonna okay alright so
they probably do you have any cigars
here for chance and the guys actually
yeah in the shoot and it's in the corner
that's tucked away old humidor that had
net clearly never been opened and we
open it up and there was a Romeo
Giulietta in there and it did you know
the tube in the tube Oh kind it had the
old label the old silver label before
they even rear-ended and it could have
been the best cigar whoever it was
paraded private eating there for ten
years the guy had never sold a cigar was
to cut the fuzz off of them so what do
you do then is it just the municipality
of Burbank where you can't smoke a cigar
Burbank and I'm sure other cities but I
know because I live so close but I tell
you it's so controlling of people's it's
so it's so infantilizing you know an
adult cannot decide whether he'll smoke
a cigar or not in an enclosed place
right you you know I used to go on Bill
Maher show a lot when he was on ABC and
and then you know then he moved and I
have been on because I don't broadcast
Friday nights but the for religious
reasons but anyway I on his show once I
live up it's a long time ago and the the
you at that time you were at least at
least fifty feet from the audience at
least and I asked people no no it wasn't
it was here was Bill Maher's anyway
asked so how many of you think you're
gonna be hurt by by secondhand smoke and
most of the hands went up yeah I mean
it's it's so easy to frighten people
irrationally it's scary
well explain that for it because a lot
of people still believe that who are
watching but you're you obviously know
better there was research that when they
finally actually conducted the research
it's not nearly as harmful as people
thought it was well first of all it is a
brazen lie and it's terrible when
science is used for propaganda it is a
total lie the fifty thousand people a
year die of secondhand smoke I don't
deny that a baby that has
that has asthma will be exacerbated if
he's in a little room with the cigar
smoke or cigarette smoke of course I
understand that use your common sense
yeah does it bother you does it make you
coughed ever I won't do it that's fine
but killing people from secondhand smoke
Oh give me a break I was in in northern
Michigan I told you this story and I had
a little just a little Perdomo cigarillo
there there huh baño and I was smart so
that thing makes a lot of smoke and I
was smoking it walking down the street
little tiny cigarillo and the sky was
with his wife INGOs that's right yet a
pot leaf on his shirt and I'm sitting
there like if only I were smoking a
joint it wouldn't be a problem and
that's smoke what's your so what is your
stance on that as some people start
doing that phony cough around electronic
cigarettes that's just healthy oh I know
I know I've seen it I've seen people do
that exactly
that's pure pure psychology well and you
know what's funny though and this is a
good example what we're talking about I
decided to let those people walk on by I
was sitting at a park bench while my
wife retrieved some olive oils fine
olive oil she's very into olive oils in
balsamics and this guy walks by and he
goes oh a stogie that reminds me of my
grandfather he was from the old country
and we had a conversation about his
grandfather we talked for 20 minutes and
he moved on as with his day nice guy
just me said thanks for that memory I
appreciate it and it does seem to be a
bonding experience of a lot of people
maybe just because it's been so
ostracized now that's part of it but I
don't know but you were right about
having something to do it's amazing that
that alcohol has not been demonized and
tobacco has I wrote about that 30 years
ago mm-hmm how sick that is how many
people baluster child after a cigar or a
cigarette and how many after alcohol
well if you're counting pill Clinton
isn't with the interns with a cigar but
I don't think it's station no it was
excuse the polls excuse results a little
bit yes is it I'm not a Clinton fan but
it's not mono station it's credit where
it's due
that's a good Pilate will say where do
you line up then on on on marijuana and
and how do you sir I hate marijuana
marijuana tampers with your brain this
doesn't so do you think marijuana should
be legal people who want to smoke it in
their house or where do you end up on
that III
my view was if it had always been legal
I would not have voted to outlawed but
since it was already illegal I don't
know what we have gained by making it
legal I know there people are needed for
medicinal reasons nobody has a problem
with it I have a an emotional it's one
of the rare times I acknowledge an
emotional reaction I am a child of the
60s 70s and I saw so many of my friends
just to not of life as they would you
know just have wheat you know they'd
smoke stick after stick and i-i-i i have
an egg attempt is with the brain yeah
III am I'm really really opposed to and
they inhaled to that's one thing by the
way the one thing I will say but for us
you don't inhale is there's no effect no
that's one thing that I will say cigar
smokers and general just want to be left
alone they're not telling anyone it
cures cancer they're not telling anyone
that if that Big Pharma is suppressing
it in my experience and by the way I
think of states wanna legalize marijuana
I don't smoke marijuana I'm not a fan of
it personally this is a very
controversial position but I think if
States want to do it go ahead and do it
yourselves but they claim it cures
everything what's crazy is they claim
it's not a performance-enhancing drug
and a lot of athletic commissions they
want people to be able to smoke
marijuana and then they go around and
say it sharpens you and it makes you
more brilliant and it's this it's this
miracle drug there is a remarkable
inconsistency with it seems to me cigar
smokers just just want to be left alone
that's what I've seen yeah exactly
but I I admit that I have a positive
view I don't I don't merely think it
doesn't hurt I think that of all the
vices it's about as harmless as exists
now wait you do inhale no no no no I buy
retro hell the nose yeah but that's you
know the that just you do you do that
don't you don't someone that someone
taught me that I don't know how to get
it through my nose and I don't want to
learn oh well you get you got to let
someone told me this is actually
Sagat a cigar expert from I think from
aficionado and he said yeah you get all
the flavors you said you kind of you
puff and you just let it go out the nose
and you get different flavors and
actually you'll get entirely different
flavors ones that arrive I'm surprised
that I'm telling you anything about
cigars that you don't I'm surprised too
I admit it
all right well there you go well give it
give it a whirl it can be and you can a
particularly there's a very strong
pepper note you notice cigars for people
I'm gonna give it a verb I'll say I'm
gonna Crowder now Matt if you want to be
popular at the cigar lounge I mean that
that punk who dressed up like a lady and
interviewed Wendy Davis we're not sure
he's on our side
what what what do you look for in a
cigar because they're all different
kinds what kind of flavor profile
exactly what people say to me cuz so a
lot of people give me a gift of cigar
when they come to speeches and stuff I
tell them because they don't know
anything about it I said go into a cigar
place and tell them the following I
would like the strongest a best cigar
you non non-cuban
for up to the following price okay
that's all I care why not timon not like
I've never there is not a single Cuban
cigar I've smoked that I've liked I like
Nicaraguan and Dominican and Honduran
what why is that do you think it's just
I don't know I don't know huh why don't
why don't I like you know I mean given
food it's just it's my taste buds do not
respond to Cuban cigars yeah I did not
enjoy them you know for other the
rationale Bible there's a lot of
irrational I don't know I don't know I
just don't like Asian I will say that in
the commentary it's true I'm it's why
it's called the rationale Bible I know I
appreciate that that you say that you
know I have heard and this is something
to be could educate me on I've heard
that Cubans think about it just like
anything socialism communism once they
were taken over by the government I
think they may have ruined their cigars
I think most people think of Cuban
cigars there it's it's at the legend not
the reality
I'm Nicaragua makes spectacular sand I
love strong it's funny this amount of
alcohol I get a headache the strong a
cigar
I'm mr. happy were you always that way
yeah always
you know that's there's something but
you should probably do something
testing would be interesting with your
with your brain type probably some what
they refer to as ADHD or because a lot
of people get very stimulated by cigars
or cigarettes or any nicotine for me
it's yeah but I'm gonna be going now two
weeks to Eastern Europe to give some
lectures and I I won't be able to smoke
nearly as much I'll look up I am as far
from addicted even though I smoke every
day but I but I'm not addicted because I
know if you can go I can go two weeks
three weeks and it's a non-issue you
want to hear something funny this is
true when everyone had that brung I had
a bronchial infection a sinus infection
from hell and so I went two weeks we
used to smoke pipes it was very
intermittent it was maybe once every
couple of weeks and with cigars now it's
it's much more frequent because I just I
enjoy them and because of you I've taken
notes and I'm going through a whole
cigar book now and my producer and I we
actually keep a book of the labels on
there um but I went two weeks without
smelling any cigars of course I was sick
and then I just I was doing the
nebulizer and steaming and I said to
hell with this I feel like crap I'm
gonna try a cigar and guess what I
coughed up what seemed to be a Ridley
Scott film creature with a cigar and I
got it's like it's not the best for
smoking no that won't be in the next
Arturo Fuente magazine it's you know a
lot of people don't realize that that
Cuban a lot of the seeds come from Cuba
the soil was great and then there was no
competition left in Cuba when I came to
cigars it's whatever Fidel wanted Fidel
got and so a lot of the really great
rollers left to Nicaragua Honduras and
Dominica Dominican Republic correct
that's it yeah could you give us a like
a couple I know you you do this in your
private email oh so I don't wanna I
don't want to let the cat out of the bag
can you give us a couple of your
favorite cigars for people yeah sure
but understanding I'm I my favorite
thing is to try a new cigar whenever I
go to a cigar lounge I go show me
something strong and good that I haven't
smoked anyway I love all of the things
called my father have you seen those I
do I like the the bees you as my trait a
favorite from theirs I think John likes
the judge the most yeah the judges
they're both great that my father is
very tasty again it's on the strong side
but that's what I like and of course I
love Lafleur
dominicana ee heroes because they're the
SuperDuper strong mm-hmm - ee Ferro not
the one leaf arrow is not strong enough
it's all about Tula heresy either way
some yes some of the patron anniversaire
OHS are very yummy mm-hmm at or off one
day is honor you know so is hit and miss
yeah it's got a very good reputation and
it deserves it whenever I see Rush
Limbaugh he gives me an hour off one day
which is very sweet of him nice and you
know off the top of my head those are
those are some of my my favorite Oliva
makes a good cigar I know what I like
box pressed have you had the the CEO
flat heads at all I probably did but I
don't have any recollection a whether or
not it's the litter it's literally a
cube and the label looks like an old
muscle car so this thing is six by sixty
they have in smaller Vitello's but they
also have a seven by seventy called a
big block which mean we do a writing
binge and we write a bunch of sketches
and commercials we sit outside and we we
have one of those it's very it's very
it's got a very very strong sort of fig
flavor you know that some cigars had
that like date fig ray yeah the flavors
are the best it really isn't
I tend to like the hub but this is just
me speaking you can cry I noticed I tend
to like the spicier cigars the Habano
wrappers the with that kind of almost
wasabi effect that's kind of what I call
it you and I mean where it gives you
that whoosh of spice and cedar that's
kind of in my profile I've gravitated
toward I am not believe it or not I
never quite resonate they say chocolate
or they say spice spice yes that's the
one thing I can I can identify with but
otherwise I either just like it or I
don't right I don't analyze why I just
at but my wife loves coffee
I love cigars it enhances her life this
enhances mine I really I'm grateful to
God for creating it and what am I gonna
tell you it's that's the way well we
can't go much longer so I believe with
it one thing I do think that is
important to note for people out there
who don't know like I said you don't
inhale
cigarettes for example have over I've
read as high as 400 something active
chemicals that can be added to it
there's no paracin right it's not it's
dishonest to love cigars and cigarettes
just dishonest there's one ingredient in
this tobacco and that's you explain to
the audience three different there's the
the filler the binder and the wrapper
and can you explain for audience who
might not know what that that means yeah
the filler is the thing you see the most
of what the ash that's right that's but
you really are the binder is what keeps
it together and the the wrapper is what
you see on the outside the wrapper is
the place of most taste right most of
the flavor now not because of the smoke
wood because this in direct contact with
your mouth right right okay so that's
now final words for people who might be
interested I'm not do do not if you are
not of age and if you do not if you have
a proclivity to an addictive personality
do not partake morning okay go legally
I'm covered what would you recommend for
people out there who are looking to get
started my brother started to tell them
I'm a novice I watched Crowder and
Praeger they convinced me that this is
one of the harmless joys of life for
most people what would you give a
beginner sir and show me how to light it
cut it and that would be a blast for
somebody to try it would and you know
what my brother how do you know when
you're done because my I'm getting
second-degree burns yeah that's well
that's a little cigarillo those burn
very second-degree burns on fingers just
fine it's my brother actions in LA and
started a cigar and pipe club at his
church and it's proven to be immensely
popular if ever you want to connect with
them with some great company great young
conservative activists I'm sure they
love to speak with you but I know you're
a busy man final question before I go
what is your philosophy that the reason
I picked this is because it's longer and
I thought I could maybe snip it and
salvage it later do you ever do that do
you ever blow it absolutely okay
absolutely and I I don't understand why
anybody would object it's yummy later
too
so what do I what's the best way to do
this that's correct you you first of all
dump your rash completely okay all right
all right and then put this you know
about you know an eighth of an inch of
of the fire part and by the way for
those who know I take it she I have a
sheep cutter specifically ripeness oh I
could tell here it's cheap
yeah yes thank you very much about about
like that yeah okay and then I'm gonna
try to do this on camera here make sure
yeah you gets hard to do it damn it yeah
it looks like it might unravel a little
bit later but you know what and then do
I do you put this in a ziploc bag or
just leave it out that's right yes
put it in a ziploc bag there we go look
look at all the stuff we learned with
dennis prager and look at the good
camera even even without a cigar in his
hand but I do want to do the fireside I
know you invited me out when I'm in Los
Angeles I will do that come on exactly
and just all you people know I mean we
got a like a half a million viewers
every week and I just talk about life to
the camera take questions and it's at
Prager University the fireside chat they
can google it and it makes a lot of
sense for a a thinking man a brilliant
man a man who Ponder's a man who gets
into philosophy so I highly recommend
this book we've plugged it so many times
on this show but Exodus the rationale
Bible I think people will really like
and appreciate out there atheists and
believers alike thank you so much mr.
Prager for coming on and I look forward
to seeing you see you and bless you and
my friend this video subscribe or click
the notification bell right next to the
subscription but because subscribing
doesn't mean anything anymore now
according to the YouTube gods and if you
like the late-night show you can watch
it every single day a full hour at LOD
with credit com / mug Club subscribe
there that way we aren't beholden to the
evil YouTube overlords and we don't have
to start playing video games with mouths
sound effects or children react